Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina Vincent.
Your burps are just
violent rips? Yeah. Yeah.
All
right.
How angry would your mom get along?
Let it let it
good.
Your books the best because I feel
like they always tell a story.
Please.
Good.
My point.
Yeah.
Good.
We do my language.
I can't listen to it and drying
my last episode I had a really,
I'm going to pass
a
good stuff.
I feel like he made a real song here.
It was really good.
Who is this western?
Oh says west as it really funny.
I was laughing really hard as
long as called Burp. No Shit.
Artists is called West. That's
west. You know what? I love
my favorite bourbon. That
is when you go back,
when it's half out and you
muffle the second half. Yeah.
Where did you pick that
technique? I don't know. You know,
I've just been in the game so long.
I just have so many different
skills to really do whatever.
I want to kind of an innovator,
if you will.
How long have you been using that
burp technique? Years. Many years.
I have a wide range of abilities
when it comes to bourbon.
I think you notice it in that song. You
definitely conceded that I am the burp.
No I did not.
You said I did not say that said you're
definitely the better Berber that I
didn't say the phrase burp champion. Well
yeah, but you said it without saying it.
That that's probably from an episode
like 200 back and that's before I
listen to what you said. Pregnancy
changed my burp games. Violent rips.
I liked the reps.
Yeah.
That statement taken from our show. Yeah.
Like 200 episodes ago. No, it was
pretty reasonable. This one. Yeah.
Yeah.
That's me.
That's me. That's me.
I'm doing the loud ones.
I feel like they always tell a story.
Yeah, I'm the BURP champ. But I
didn't say you're the verb champion.
I didn't use to have to say it.
What it is,
it's not implicit.
All I said is I liked yours
the best because they have
different sounds. Pitches.
They do tell a story.
I like when you go half into
the sometimes you like that.
Why don't you try it? Cause it's your
technique. I can't or you can try it. No,
it's not. It's not mine. Mine's
different. I like to go aggressive.
You heard what I was capable of
and that song, I'd like surprises.
That's,
that's a going,
can I have some of your doctors
evs to get my own burps going.
Your whole thing is like,
I want somebody yours.
That's because yours is better than my,
I don't know why you do that.
It's really ridiculous. It
just tastes better. It tastes
good. Tastes good. A bitch.
Um, but you're, you're burbs
consistently make me laugh. Um,
probably that's probably why.
One of the main reasons I married
you and your burps in here.
One of the main reasons. I
mean, there's other stuff like,
are you a good person? Are you not
addicted to things? Do you call, you know,
like do what you're saying, are you going
to do keep your word, are you moral?
But above all that is, can you Burke? Wow.
I didn't realize it was that
high on the list. Well, yeah,
because I've actually addicted to things.
That's a little important to a lot,
but I, I dated guys in the
past who don't like by,
they didn't like my burbs where my farts
and I got a lot of heat for being who I
was. Really. So when I found you
I was like, Oh really? Oh yeah.
I have upset.
Every ex boyfriend did not appreciate
my burping or farting skills.
Wow.
Fall in.
I got a lot of heat for my burbs. Like
the last boyfriend I had before you. Yeah.
He actually would be like,
stop farting. Stop it.
Like he would get really mad at me.
He didn't appreciate it.
That's why I can't hear it. The
thing is done. That's why. Okay. O is
for is for
far.
Yeah. I liked that burp that I did
on the show that made the teaser.
That was a pretty, I mean, I
wish you'd give me some credit.
I feel like you just want to Laurie and
I don't get it. What about my farts?
Remember you came home and I farted a
lot yesterday. Very cool. In the kitchen.
I farted a bunch and there's
no shortage of parts from you.
I mean if that's what this is about, well
who's a better, okay, let's decide then.
Who's a better fighter?
Who was a bit of Roper?
You really want to have that discussion
right now. He really thinks so.
Well why not?
Why can't we just have the discussion?
It doesn't have to lead anymore.
Let's just open up a topic. You know,
you know the answer.
What's the answer?
I'm definitely the king supreme of
both of those categories. Not True.
Yana.
Yana might.
I present the case of my farts being
very smelly and hot cause I eat a lot of
dried apricots in the past.
I tend to have smellier hotter
farts than you think so. Yeah.
Mine smell way worser than
yours. Sometimes they do.
Most of the time they do.
I think we're going to vomit during this.
There's so much gross stuff in this
episode. Last conversation is one of them.
Definitely the BURP champ.
I can't believe you wouldn't concede that.
I don't know. I feel like that's
up for debate. I feel like,
I just feel like we need to open it up
and let's kind of see where it says I'm
not ready to call that yet. Okay.
I feel like it's warm in here.
It's not warm in here. You're always hot.
We'll take off your fucking sweatshirt.
We'll know because it's like comfortable.
But I mean the other day I take off the
sweatshirt aware these sweatshirts comes
or not hot anymore. It's comfortable to
wear it though. That's what I'm saying.
But here's what Howard tour
that was pretty good. This
is how ridiculous it was.
Just looked at it to see how it registered
and how did it register? Pretty hot.
Pretty hot.
How is yours and comparison go back to it.
You didn't look when yours.
I mean you,
you did it like a real theatrical
appropriate then though. Really forced to,
so what you're saying, what
you're saying is, is that you,
you're good with a variety.
I might be good with sound.
See I like,
I like that right there cause it had
different sounds and then you incorporate
it at the end.
My favorite Burberry or is when you used
to go when the mouth and then blow it
out?
Yeah.
I mean you're talking about all these
different burps right now and you're like,
those are cool down one's called. They'll
be like, that one's cool. That was cool.
But then you go. But I mean,
who says you're the best? Well,
who does all these different verbs?
It's me. I'm obviously the boat.
We haven't decided what criteria is the
best. Okay. And in my opinion, yeah,
variety is important,
but so is pitch frequency volume.
Very important. Yeah. So
I think I have the volume.
I have the fortune to talk about
how ridiculous you are. Oh,
that light's off by the
way. Oh Shit. Fuck. Hold on.
You guys can look at my light denim that
I got. Oh yeah, she's got real light dad.
But I'll tell you why.
Because these are lucky brand and
they're like a nineties Jean that I
specifically order online. Pretty nerdy
colored. Yeah. But the cut is cool.
Look,
it looks kind of cool though.
Cool.
Yeah. Dad, where did the uh, white sneaks
yeah.
Should close this door.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. Definitely.
I know another another day of rain.
You want me to hold the heat? Yeah. No,
I'm going to turn the
air on so cold. Why? Why?
Why are you doing this? Why aren't
you doing this? You're miserable. No,
Dad. You're the worst. How cold
are you going to make it in here,
Jean? You have such unreasonable
expectations for this.
The other day I was in bed and I
go, is it warm in here? No. I go,
it smells warm and I kind of just like,
I let your logical mind step in
for a second and then I go, wait,
this doesn't feel right and I
get up and I work. I miss that.
And it's 80 it's 80 and you're
like, I like it. It feels good.
Here's a problem with what you do or I
don't like your methods is because it'll
be hot as fuck outside.
I don't feel it kicking on,
so you don't feel it.
Jesus. Oh my God. Oh my God.
So listen,
my problem with your AC consumption is
that it'll be hot as fuck outside and
then you'll decide to put it down to
like 60 never, never once. Not even once.
You said you want it to be
63 never done it. Never.
How low do you put that
thermostat because of you?
It feels like 63 I should
say that because of you.
I always put it at 72 73
silo like that please.
The problem is you turn it to low and
then it feels like keep it in the low
seventies not even down to seven
but it feels like I have a fever.
I don't feel like you have a fever.
It makes me feel feverish and sick when
you make the AC so cold and it's been
hot all day,
so my body's all super high.
Whenever I see you and then you
overcompensate with whatever.
I see you being feverish and sick.
I feel so happy and I feel so
good with myself, you know,
kind of smaller. And your soda.
Where's your water? Water Champ. Oh,
interesting. Yet another
episode where you have no water.
Every two beverages with you. Ha, I
have coffee and I have water id hydrate,
but then I rehydrate.
That's my system.
The whole thing I do is
I don't dehydrate ever.
So he also don't drink water and I do.
The thing is water champion,
not beverage champion. I drink gallons
of water were not during the show.
I don't know how you go in there right
now because I drank so much before. Oh,
really? Yeah. Okay.
That's your story. Plus,
this is water soda.
Why naturally flavored?
No Art, no sugar, no artificial
sweeteners, no caffeine.
Fun at all. Water. Yeah. Oh it whatever.
I always thought the clear stuff
that comes from the tap is water,
but you're,
you're claiming the Black Cherry
via soda is the same as water it is.
It's exactly the same molecularly. Well,
it has some carbonation in it. Okay.
Add some flavorings that make it not
taste. Why no artificial sweetener,
don't you just drink water if you
like water or something like that.
Do I drink it all day? I drink gallons
of senior drink. Any water today.
You're a liar, but you live in
a lie. What's the light? Okay,
now you're performing. You're forcing it.
You're forcing it. You're the lightship.
That'll you're either lie champ.
He's a liar champ. You're the liar.
Chances are willing to
share the cold champion.
You like it cold like your heart ready.
Let's do this shit.
I've been, I'm very,
very dirty ground lately.
For some reason I've been going two, three
days without showering. Oh No. I know.
It's pretty bad.
It is.
But it's not all bad because since I'm
not showering as often as I probably
shut,
that means that my asshole
probably has a nice stinky sent to it.
Oh is Randy.
Don't bring anyone loving coded.
Well welcome to your mom's house for us
Christina pledges.
It's interesting
she hasn't showered in three days, but
that means on the good side. Yeah, this,
she's got real stinky be whole.
That is a positive.
So I thought you were going to say she's
not wasting water but that too. Yeah,
that too. How, what's the longest
you've gone without showering?
Definitely a couple of days, but
not, not often, man. I mean, uh,
yeah. I'm trying to think of like
sickness Leben like really sick.
You stay in bed and it hurts to
stand. That kind of stuff. Yeah,
a couple of days maybe into the third day,
you know,
or some crazy outdoors. Each trip
that I took, I dunno as this guy,
I don't even do that.
I'm the indoor champ period.
I haven't done it in a long time. Hey,
can't, I'll never can't to my life. Yeah.
We got so much flack from that.
Uh, what one episode, I don't know,
hundreds of episodes ago where we're
like, fuck camping. You're wrong.
Like I don't want to go dude. And they're
like, but you're missing out. No, I'm not.
I've been before. Right.
I don't want to go.
It doesn't mean I don't like it
outside. I like being outside. Yeah.
I just don't want to say we've gotten
there. I liked it. I like lakes. Yeah.
I like stuff. I know I like going
outdoors. I just don't want to,
I don't see the need to sleep
out there for days on end,
but that's what's funny to me.
Shit out there and stuff.
When somebody argues against
someone's preferences. Right.
You know, it's like, it's like someone
arguing with about your food preferences.
Yeah. You know, if you're
like, I'm meeting the soup
and they're like, I hate soup,
you should try this. And you're
like, but I like it. Right.
But they're usually like what I
liked. Yeah. Like would I like that?
Why don't you like my stuff?
I Dunno. I Dunno man. Nope.
I like sneaky bought wholesale and this
lady's got one, so she set it up. Well,
now I know what's going to happen. I
think. Oh, I don't know. I'm lost today.
I thought I would play with my ass home.
No,
stick my finger really deep.
Far.
Wait a minute. She's gonna get shit on
her finger. No. Yeah. All up in there.
Maybe she's training.
Take it out and inhale.
Yeah, she published stones as field. Wow.
Yeah. Maybe that's a spam. I don't
know. Maybe she's trying to train
Glen. What's your ass smells like?
What's your cock and balls smell like?
Yeah. That, that is one of my favorite
clips. Learn what your cock and balls.
Learn your finger along
the crack of your ass.
You don't need to finger your whole,
you don't want to come back
with shit on your finger.
But here's somebody that wants
to take that advice to task.
Maybe you can say, I don't think so, sir.
You're not the only one that knows how
to run your finger along ass. All right,
let's
just talk about what sense I'm getting.
Oh, what kind of smells or
living in my asshole right now,
because trust me,
there's probably a lot of smells
going on in my asshole right now.
Talk like you, I mean, I was gonna
say one of my sisters, but yeah,
she is a girl. This is a woman might be
related to you. Seriously. Seriously.
Seriously. Seriously.
Seriously. Oh my God. Seriously?
She sounds like you. And
then she's like, say, uh,
as a lot of smells loud that
here is a tribal tattoo.
That's a neat,
let's see here is my sister.
Oh my God. Seriously. And then
here's this lady. Seriously,
seriously. Oh my God. Seriously.
Oh Man. So is that it's like you
think she's got some real smells,
you know,
I'm not so worried about the smells.
I'm worried about that tribal tat that
she has around her arm. That kind of
Barb wire nineties. My own included. Yeah.
And if you're watching this,
you probably love asked smell too.
Oh, so this is an f smell
video? Like that's like, yeah.
What did you think she thought maybe
she was just somebody who has, you know,
sexual videos up. I didn't know
it was like specific. She goes,
if you're watching this, you'd like asked
smells. This is cool. From an ass smell.
Yes. I think so. This is a
very specific genre. I can't,
oh my God. Seriously. I can't
imagine this is like generalized.
It's all about ass smells. Oh my
God, you guys are so disgusting.
That was Jane by the way. People
sometimes don't know he was doing, uh,
which sister is doing the voices, right?
You know, or what they're hearing. Yeah,
that's Jane. Yeah. Maria. I
don't know. Can we find them?
Maria thing to do the difference.
Fingers,
cut the bomb vest on and like throw myself
out because I'm basically on map hat
with the lifestyle. It's very fucking
healthy lifestyle. He asked me,
they kind of sound the first half of that.
Yeah, that's real. Yeah, it's different.
It's a faster cadence.
Much faster. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. Okay. So let's get back to this
stinky ass hole. These ladies here,
real curious
about it. Something Raunchy. Yeah.
Intoxicating.
Seriously.
Someone can sit on my face all day with
her ass and I wouldn't mind sitting in
someone else's space, smothering
with, smothering them with my dirty,
smelly asshole.
She kind of talks like you kind of has,
well this is kind of vocal fry or so,
right? Yeah. I mean, do you
think she talks like me?
Yeah. Like I feel like you two
could be a nice pair in a way.
I mean, she was nasty. She had nasty
as fuck. But you're like, you're,
you're open to nasty like that,
you know,
I dunno if I would be farting or
when he named Justin Myself. Uh,
I don't know if I would necessarily
be into the ass male aspect of,
of the relationship with her.
Like if she was like,
I didn't shower days wants to smell,
but she's inside of my ass.
But she's definitely got kind of a
Karen vibe to her. Yeah. I mean she's,
she's a nasty bitch for sure.
She's a crystal or a Shandy.
She's gnarliest. Fuck Trish.
She's kind of a Trish. Trish that
Karen. Yeah. Karen is broken,
but she's not this damaged
this girl. A Trish. Sure.
She is a little more sophisticated.
And Karen though. Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought I thought Tricia was trashy or
my mind. No, Tris thinks he has a shot.
Remember? No, Karen thinks she has a shot.
Trish doesn't trick Tricia's trashier
than Karen. No, I don't think so.
Have I messed up my alter
ego? I think so. Yeah. Yeah.
That's not it. Um, all right,
let's see what this, uh, yeah,
cause it's so cold in here.
I feel sick because I'm warm under
my sweatshirt and then the 74,
it's freezing. Freezing. You feels
like studios, there's cold air around.
It keeps studios in the 60s always.
I wore this white shirt today is because
I knew it was cold out and I knew you
would still turn on the AC. It's not,
it's not clean. That's why I wore this,
because I put my hood up for him.
His lights that generate heat in here.
Yes. It's not as nice.
Why don't we stop? No,
please don't.
No, you want me to sue other
my panties all over your face.
You inhale.
It's gotta be real stake here. How do
you know if she's telling the truth?
I don't. I wonder. That same
thing. Yeah, she's lying.
The two to three day thing could be.
I don't think she really is into it
the way she pretends to be. You know?
Oh Jesus. Fuck. Are we
done with this yet? I mean,
my stomach's hurting from watching this.
It smells stronger then I
thought I would smell. Oh Wow.
It's like a combination of a Raunchy ass
and sweet shits now, but in a good
way. You know? Not Dirty Shit.
Oh my God.
You guys are so disgusting.
Let's see what's happening.
This is blurred.
Blurred this hall.
No,
you get all the natural
smells of my asshole.
I mean, she's really doing
it. Yeah, I know. I get it.
A little coercing cause my finger is dry,
but I don't want to get
all the real smells.
That's the important thing.
The real smells. Oh, okay.
Oh, oh fuck. Um, no.
You know what? She's authentic. That's
what I respect. Sweetness. Do Smell.
I can't,
we can't fake this level.
So if you're one of her followers,
that's my girl.
She's not as my jam.
Christina's Janice.
She's authentic. I
believe her now. I wasn't,
I wasn't convinced when she showed us her,
she spread them and then I
wasn't convinced when she
was sniffing her panties.
I do feel like in order to be the kind
of girl you put your finger in your butt
and that smell and then describe the
smell. You're committed. Like you're,
you're in it. You're in it, you're in
it. You're real. She's real. She's real.
She's real.
No thanks asshole.
Yeah,
she's three days
crazy laugh. She's, she's a crazy
lady. Crazy. She's crazy. What do you,
things like the data, right?
Right, right. Nobody dates her.
No one on one dates hurts.
People start to date or,
and then it doesn't go that long.
No.
How long before you realize how crazy
she is? But it's also something good.
It's just raunchy ass and shit smell.
I mean that's basically what it is.
And I fucking love it and I don't care.
And I know you love it too.
I'm going to throw us too.
She is gnarly
getting that Hashtag.
Uh, what do you think it,
how long before,
how long do you think
Rhonchi ass and shit smell?
Do you think she leads with us?
Like is this,
she has to meet people on like fetish
site. I don't know if she leaves
is with this, but she doesn't, she
doesn't completely mask it either.
I think she's the kind of person
who you're having dinner, right?
Talking about this and that.
And then she might be like,
I like stinky stuff.
It's smelly cheeses.
Like she might lead you into
or she'll say something like,
I didn't put on deodorant today. Right.
And then you're like, oh, you know,
that's okay.
Do you like that you don't like what?
There's a Dwayne reed across the
street if you want to go there.
And then she's like, I don't
want to buy any. I'm saying,
do you like the way that smells? And
you're like, oh, I don't think so.
Then she's like, I like doing my
fucking asshole smells. And you're like,
we should probably get the cheque.
Yeah. Yeah. It does go down like that.
Yeah. You think she drops it
on the first date though? Yeah.
I think when you have a fetish,
uh, this real, you gotta Let,
he's not playing games.
She's real
full note. A lot of smells going
on in my asshole right now.
You see that too? Like try a lot of
smells going on in my ass asshole.
But for different reasons.
Not for sexual,
I don't say I don't think go and I want
to smell each one of them on my finger.
And you're usually, you say that
when you have to shower, you're like,
oh my sticky asshole. Yes. Thank you.
But that her finger would have brown
on it. It didn't, it didn't know God.
Interesting observation.
It did not.
Well yeah cause that was another level
of gnarly that I thought was coming,
you know,
wait,
she didn't get shit on her fingers and
she fingered her bottle so that the pup
play guys kind of off. And you
think yeah, but maybe, I don't know.
Maybe she just has like a cleaner pothole.
She's a girl.
She's a girl or a way gnarlier
she could have even, you know,
tried to remove some inner brown.
Who knows.
Well,
speaking of dudes being gnarly,
a while ago we gave some advice to a
young gentleman about what to do about a B
hall shaves.
He writes in,
I wrote you a couple of weeks ago asking
if I should do some maintenance down
under after listening
to your words of wisdom,
I made the decision to bic my be whole.
I didn't go with the waxing because I
didn't know if I was committing to a good
thing. Well it was a game changer.
Uh, just like you had said,
my cleanup game is pretty fucking tight
right now. Just a few wipes and done.
There is the sweat issue that you
mentioned, but that's a welcome trade off.
I was surprised to notice how my farts
smell different now to kind of sloppy
sounding like a fat Guy Fart.
I also changed my diet as you suggested
by removing most of the carbs and almost
all sugar. That's made a huge
difference in my life in many ways.
I feel like a new man and I can't
thank you enough. Fuck Dan Pena.
My life coach is the one and only
undisputed water champion Tommy Bond.
Thanks.
And I bow and thank you for your thanks.
Well it's neat on this show and we can
help people. It is cool. And you know, I,
it was easy to give that advice.
I thought that it was a,
the idea was one that I would go for and
I think that the Diet changes, you know,
it's modest. It's not too crazy to do
that. Change is key to farts. Oh yeah.
And the heat,
they probably,
he said they feel diff or they
smell different or sound different.
Sound different. That's
right. The hair is gone.
So it's just really going against skin.
It's in the air and the skin is,
it says what girl fart sound like. Yeah.
Girl forests on different, yeah, for sure.
So I'm, I'm very proud of him
though for doing it and I, you know,
I encourage people to at least
take that hair removal for a spin.
See if it's something that feels
right to you, is fun to you.
Well, there's lots of benefits.
You got a cleaner wipe. Yeah. Uh,
it is sweaty like he said,
but you know, trade off. I'd
say the cleanup thing is, is
massive. The cleanups, the whole point,
everything else is, uh, you know,
has his, uh, you know, uh, whatever
effect of it. But it's not, it's not,
it's all about the cleanup challenging
cause when you're a hairy man, that is,
I can't imagine the suffering.
I can't imagine shitting into the
top of your head and then being like,
seriously, and then just wiping the
fish shit off of it. And you're like,
how long is it going to take? I
don't know, 45 minutes. Speaking of,
speaking of that an we got
bringing water to Poop,
it's called Christina is wrong.
Here's the email Solomon get
this straight Christians uh,
yeah is freaking out about Dj Dad Mal
bringing a water bottle into the stall but
her jam is to wash it off of her.
How do you say rectum in the shower.
I guess there is some risk of airborne
brown particles attaching to the small
surface area exposed on a water him
after the bottle cap is removed,
but that's only a short amount of
time and the risk of contamination is
negligible and any non juggle,
oh person would ditch that water bottle
after bringing it into the shit or
obviously chugging most of the water
before bringing it into the hydrate water
champ. Is it lifestyle? He probably
starts out saying it doesn't smell,
it doesn't burn it and greasy,
I mean step on my balls,
but brown should not be
washed off onto a surface.
You routinely walk barefoot in a puddle
of water unless you are bleaching your
shower every day, but get your life only
using dove body wash. So main mommy.
Tina was suspiciously shocked and
couldn't barely recognize buttons after
hearing this pro level move.
I'm no professional but sounds like a
subconscious retaliation effort from a
personality of lesser character.
I mean it's basically f
a r t level hypocrisy.
Wow. If you swap out poop
particles for curse words for,
for curse words, for analysis,
you feel me? Smart and final mark
smartify armor. Yeah. Well
first of all, mark, uh,
list off a r t allow me to uh,
clarify my position on Tom's usage of the
water bottle to clean off her ass hole.
He is right by the way.
And that you don't take a,
I'm a taking a full bottle of
water and cracking it to do this.
What are you doing? This is a like,
let's say an airport. You have,
you buy your bottle of water,
you're drinking it.
Let's say you're probably two
thirds of the way through it.
I gotta take a dump. I bring that
in there and it helps me clean up.
Now you're using like the maple syrup top,
you know,
the kind that's like the power squirter.
Is that what you're doing? And you're,
you're kind of supporting your asshole
or your wedding. The toilet paper.
Toilet paper. Well, my only thing just
go like this. You pour water into,
now you have wet toilet paper.
Okay.
To wash the top of your head off
that you shit on my own way. Uh, my,
my issue with it was that I was worried
about the shame of caring in a bottle of
water into the shitter. I just think
it's odd when people carry zero shame,
um,
food items are edible things
into the store would not bring.
That's kind of a cheeseburger.
I see you like you've got your Mcdonald's,
you got your Apple Pie. There is a good
idea though to eat that on the Shitter,
right? So nasty, nasty.
And secondly,
I don't do shit to shower anymore because
of the total washlet three talking
about outside of the house we're
talking about, uh, why haven't,
I haven't shit to showered in awhile,
but we're talking about how, so you're,
you're, you're at the airport
and what do you do? Right.
And so that's what I'm
saying is it's not an,
I don't bring a bottle of water into
our home. I'm saying when you're,
when you're in public, I guess I'm
thinking about the office worker,
the person who has to be,
I don't think it's that weird rule has to
go to like a bottle of water is capped.
I know, but it just seems weird. Like I'm
going to go to take a shit and then you,
you're carrying your bottle
of water in the stall with he,
you don't think people kind of know?
I wouldn't think twice because I used
to get wearied just like weird about
bringing my iPhone in to
take a shit. Like, oh,
everybody knows that I'm looking at
my iPhone. Oh, when I'm taking a dump,
which I would hide it Kinda in my clothes
so that people didn't see, I still do.
I would carry that water right in.
No problem. Right. I, but you're,
you're an animal. You don't care
about anything. That's true.
I wanted to bring this to your attention
a as long as we're still on this topic.
Yeah. Uh, our good friend
Eric, it was his birthday.
We bought him a squatty potty using our
Amazon banner and go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom,
the homepage to your shopping
as you normally would.
And I got him a squatty potty.
Right. And in Kansas shitty he lives.
Yes.
Now here's the interesting part is that
we've had so many people tell us to use
the squatty potty.
Yeah.
And I've been reluctant because
like I take healthy browns,
I don't need the assistance of anything.
Yeah. Interesting review came in.
I'm going to read what he wrote verbatim
because I find it that interesting.
Hold on one moment. One moment.
You don't have it prepped
for the show or anything
and breathe into the mic because
that's definitely loving that.
I can't find Jesus. Basically
he said, sure hour here.
Basically he said,
well he said that it's good that it comes
out faster when you're doing it right.
Like you take it faster shit cause your,
your knees are up to your chest basically.
Right.
The problem is it doesn't
leave much time for reading,
for texting, for catching up on,
you know, Instagram, Twitter,
or whatever.
That's the problem.
So part of the fun of shitting
is really catching up on emails,
texting people back.
Definitely texting your friends,
you're taking a shit right now. That kind
of stuff. It becomes a necessity. Oh,
how's it takes a while. So it really
does make sense in that you, I'm sorry,
what becomes a necessity? The
iPhone. Yeah, because you're like,
this isn't going to come out and in half
a second I'm going to sit here for a
second and then you get the engine going.
But if you're,
if you're doing that, maybe you're
happier that you have more time, you know,
in other words, you, you feel
like it's going to take some time.
That's why you bring your iPhone. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I like to take my time.
I like to catch a real dilemma though. I
understand. Yeah. Because on the one hand,
I like the efficiency of the squatty
potty. I liked the idea of, yeah. But
then again, I kind of
enjoy my, um, you know,
relaxed BMS. I like, I like texting
everybody that I'm shitting. Anything.
You already made your decision. I don't
think you're going to do it. No. Um,
I should tell this.
Are you out on this?
Oh, I like the way I
should. So Do I. Yeah,
but that was just chipping the ball right
there. But why not? Sorry. Sorry. Um,
the big announcement is chips in a mall.
I'm coming to Momster.
Eylea Oh,
good. Hey, good day mate.
Uh, that's pretty exciting. Gene. I
haven't been here in quite some time.
I'm coming in August. I'm
hitting four cities. Brisbane,
Sydney,
Melbourne and Perth.
Tickets are on sale. Better
scoop them. Shits up.
It's August. Uh, I believe
the first show was August 9th,
and then there's one the
10th, 12th, and 14th.
Go to Tom segura.com.
Click on the tour page
coming down under man.
Really excited about it. It's been
a few years since I've been to mum.
Straight Lya also coming up next
week I'm going to tits Berg,
Pennsylvania. Uh, uh,
we added a late show on Thursday.
The first one sold out,
so that is on sale now.
I will also be a new haven come
netic hunt and a Burlington,
Vermont. I'm going to do
that one on Saturday I think.
So those tickets are on
says sizzle and then,
uh, meet rattle Seattle,
Washington. I'm the,
I'm doing a second show on the 14th.
Okay. Get your tickets for that.
Like meet rattled. So just
silly. Portland, Oregon.
I had to add a show in May because of
the way that the weekend worked out.
Um, with uh, what's it called with Easter.
So I'll be coming back and
I'm doing Eugene, Oregon as
well. Oh, I like that. Yeah.
I Love Oregon, Dallas and Houston specific
work. That's definitely happening.
Fallis Texas and juiced in Texas
are definitely, I love Tahoe April.
So get your tickets.
All right
Jean, like all those places. Can I make my
big announcement too? I feel like, yeah.
After fucking a million
years in standup comedy,
I'm finally taping my first
hour of standup comedy.
Finally habitat that like
in the works for years and then
now it's finally happening and I'm,
it's happened on them. Very happy.
Proud of myself. I'm probably too,
so help me ramp up for this
taping. Um, this is all the, uh,
this is the get down. Last
looks. Final final touches. Yeah.
April 13th through 15th.
Brant Improv.
April 28th through 29th
punchline in Sacramento.
What does it Sacramento ball.
Sac town ball sacs mentos
May 4th through fifth fart.
Next Arizona stand, the blue
thrive May 19th through 20th June.
Dork titties. Gotham cum and cum in
your face club. June 1st through third.
Denver mom for mom for comedy
works the downtown location.
June 16th or 17th man.
Fran disco at the punchline,
and then my smurf day on the 18th.
And then I take June 24th.
So very exciting. Very
exciting. Vac Sinai.
I Dunno if I'll announce where yet. I'm
going to hold that though. Wait on it.
It's not an la, I'll tell you that. Yeah,
I think that'll be very exciting to have
the mommy's come out for this one will
come up big time. That'd
be great. They're exciting.
Thank you for this fresh Latin heat
fresh.
Oh, is that right? I thought
you just called it that. I
like that. No, I was like,
why you are turning into a DJ?
It's Eddie Bojangles.
It's called fresh Latin heat. You're very
handsome. You're my fresh Latin. He, whoa.
Thanks gene. You do look good today.
What's going on? What's going on? Yeah.
You Oh cause you made fitness
this morning. No, I've been
having uh, uh, cucumbers,
cucumbers,
the cucumbers,
cucumbers, and then it makes me, uh,
makes me look better. Double browns
means mineral.
It's very,
I number silica here a near get Langa
other vitamins [inaudible] until we can,
could make you look younger.
95% was that kidney cleans.
I agree at IAG attack detox by about
good regularly Leah Guy, your body,
good things don't be at,
you gotta get big back slides when
you get a jug of water overnight,
you know what you get for
a fraction of the price.
Energy drink will not be lecture lied.
Robin Salad is one of the Osa as I
basically, yeah, budget type of Joseph.
I know that's the price, but a slice on
your eyes take away the Janus revitalize.
Oh yes. One thing I have left who come
back and as a LP by breath washed away,
the bacteria that caused that o. Dot. Cook
home. My wife died instead of sold out.
I'm not going to be, I
made it. Got Him one day.
I don't think he's pronouncing it right.
Cocoon bar.
Maybe gotten Monday. Did they
resolve? I bought this. The Q code?
Yes. He knows how to say it
right there. Mine. There you go.
He talks American and then he talks
all funny after that. Goddamn,
and I got eight. Who is this guy? Let's
see. This is one of you use voice though.
I like that a lot.
Oh my greatest reggae
artists. Oh, what is it?
Macka B.
I like how it says here,
decides to a rap about how awesome
cucumbers are, but and he wrote,
decides to rape about
how awesome cucumbers.
Hmm.
Yeah. He didn't rape anything, but it
was good. That was really good. Yeah.
I like that guy's accent a lot. You do?
Yeah, I do. I like that a lot. It's fun.
Everything they say sounds real
fine when they talk that way. Yeah.
It's like when English people talk,
they just sound super smart. Yeah.
No matter what they say.
And then when like Jamaican dudes talk,
it's just sounds like it's
a party. It sounds like fun.
Mini cucumbers. Fun. Yeah.
They make everything fun. Yeah. Yeah.
So we had a good time. I'll fucking
vegetable. It sounds like a real party.
Vegetables. Fun. Well that's too much fun.
Oh, shy. Just doctor Mercola and I
want to tell you about her new product.
Fermented Broccoli sprouts in the store.
Suburbs.
Now my staff prepared this short edit
to help you better understand how
combining a special form
of organic broccoli please.
Broccoli sprouts still liver.
It's not for compound of
Broccoli sulforaphane.
Hold on.
Show business number one.
Try not to match your jacket with
the background. That's kind of funny.
Maybe it was like he's
popping out of the wall.
Just those eyeballs and a white collar.
Anything Weirdo.
Yeah, come on. Creep Salad. Secondly,
pick somebody a little more camera ready.
Then this fool, what are you trying to
say is definitely not for television.
This face? No, it's got
a face for podcasts.
Guys are bugged out the bulbous eyes,
the ears that comes out. Let's
hear more about so forth. No,
please.
Oh God,
I love cop out
and Gluco Raffin itself is not
an active biomolecule. However,
it can be converted into Sony,
which is yeah,
and so forth. Yes. The important
preventive benefits and it's a effect.
Well documented. He might have
even read about it on my site.
I probably haven't write about
it. Are we done? No, please.
And be converted to so far
thing. We're crying out. Fuck.
Using the bacteria that are
normally present there. I was
like this fuck. Like they talk. Yes,
definitely. Do you think he says
like, well right now the uh,
the vaginal juices are making it.
This is a lubricant.
It's a natural lubricant is telling
you about it. You do it? Yes, he does.
I believe it.
Do you know I had a listener from
nasty bro and she listens to the show.
She's like a bio chemist. Super
Genius. She wrote in, she was like,
I actually understood one
of your boring videos horse.
Somebody every week understands
a boring video or two. Yeah,
top soil.
That's my
jam.
I love it.
I love sinkholes or dry dry sockets
or whatever the fuck. Oh my God,
I had an awesome brunch. You did.
God, I haven't had brunch in forever.
Tell me about bright. Well, cause our
baby jeans is up at six in the morning.
Yeah. And then he's down by that
first nap by nine. It's not really,
there's no brunch window.
I mean I guess we could do it when he
wakes up from that or did it in Chicago.
Yeah.
What did you have?
Well, first of all, I'll tell you
the whole weekend was bananas. Yeah.
Chicago's like banana city.
No,
but I mean I did it started in Green
Bay and then I went to the trois.
And then how has the trois, my,
my former, uh, had a great time.
I was at the adjacent place.
Royal Oak Music venue.
Yeah.
And uh, crowds were amazing. So
cold in here. I need a hot beverage.
Yeah. That, that was a blast.
But then on Sunday I was with a j
Elvis Weinstein came with me and,
and then Lewis Lee who,
uh,
lives in Minneapolis came down and we
had brunch at this place called Shaws and
it was just delightful.
Nothing like a killer Brunch,
man. What did you have? I had
everything. I was off. Fuck the points.
Fuck the points. Yeah, he did it. Yeah.
Sunday morning. I'm like, um, Sunday.
Funday man,
here's the thing.
Ever since I've been a more
moderate and the focus eater,
even off the rails,
isn't that far off.
Yeah, I agree. Because you know, like
a, it's not going to feel that great.
That's the, yeah, the whole thing
want to like hurt myself. Right.
So I remember when of my way there,
I told Josh, I go, I said, dude, I'm
going deep in this shit today. Like, yeah.
And what does that mean for you?
Exactly? Going deep. Just A,
I'm going to have some sugar and
I'm going to have some carbs. I'm,
I'm not going to be like, what is,
what is that? I'm just going to eat it.
But pacifically what are the items
that you will order off the menu?
I love, you know, I'm a breakfast
maniac, so this is uh, the,
the Brunch is like a brunch buffet with
ton at this place. It was phenomenal.
So I just wanted to get like
a waffle waffle state too.
The cool thing is they
did many ones there.
Minis are the best.
That's the thing I learned is that it's
not even about having a crazy amount.
It's like getting that taste again.
Still want to make something. Well,
here's what puts a taste in my mind.
Here's what I would do with
the mini waffles is it,
get as many of those on your plate as
you can and then change up the situations
on all of them. Dude, you do like
chocolate and whipped cream on one. Yup.
And then you do your fruits on another.
Know what I'm saying?
You got some Nutella.
There I go. I have that. I have some,
some scraps had crab let, cause I
have a lot of as a seafood crab legs.
But I mean, you know, they give you
a, you know, a moderate portion. Yeah,
I had my little mini waffle,
some breakfast sausage. Yeah.
Um, I dunno, a couple of
others, like I said, gramps,
couple egg things and you're
just like, oh, I'm totally good.
So you feel like you, you had,
uh, you went off the rails,
but it wasn't that crazy.
You know?
And what I've learned too is that if I
go off the rails early in the day, yeah,
it's better.
I don't eat a lot at night.
I know I have this stuff I take after
I ate that. Does that work? I mean,
it's supposed to work and then I
asked, I exercise after too. Wow.
So you're good. So you do you balance.
Yeah. And then I do, you know,
I don't fuck around the rest of the week.
I don't like that you pick one day to go
off the rails and then you clean it up.
It was, otherwise you're going
to have problems, you know?
You know what I found too is that it's
not as fun to do the things I used to do.
Yeah. It's not as fun because I knew like,
I'm just going to get fucking fad. Yeah.
Not Worth it to get fat and shitty again.
Just cause I like eating.
I like drinking a lot of wine.
I've had to like really like curb all
that, you know, late night, evening,
start looking at sugar and things.
It blows your mind if you start,
if you start being sugar conscious,
it's really blows your mind.
Just because we were trying to make
these, uh, these Quito pancakes, um,
the Keto friendly ones,
and of course one of the components
that you have to get a sugar free syrup,
but it also has to not have,
so not only can it be,
it has to be sugar free.
It can't have the sweeteners that
affect you the way sugar does.
So it's a very specific brand.
So I was in whole farts and I asked
if they had it and they go, no,
we don't have it.
And just out of curiosity,
I picked up a regular maple syrup
and looked at the sugar grams.
You know, how many sugar grams are
in one serving. Dot. Get your life.
I can't even imagine. 53
grams. Yeah. That's like,
uh, more than a candy bar. It's more
like a snickers bar, Ryan. It's,
and then having a little bananas
stick to a serving of maple syrup.
First of all, whoever makes the servings
is fucking bullshit on any product ever.
Who just eats, ate potato chips or who
has it? I know spoon if, if they didn't,
if they didn't tell you that,
then the back of every level would terrify
half a serving is what that shit is
because sugar is the one that only up,
I think next year it changes for the
first time we're next to the grants.
That doesn't show you that the percentage
of the daily value you see sodium,
fat, protein, it shows you the
grams and then a percentage,
15% 25% sugar,
it'll say 53 grams,
no percentage.
And that's because of the sugar lobby,
but getting fucked and next year that's
neat when the business can fuck with
your health like that. So
yeah, there's a little bit,
just a tiny little bit. Yeah. And
if you don't watch your sugar,
that's right up like Bert or
you get the sugar beet is, yeah,
the B. This, um,
are you thinking of maybe
changing who you are?
[inaudible]
it's so good to know that my friends
have my back through anything.
It's just always good to
have that friend reassurance.
And especially for me it's like don't
talk to people outside of my group.
Well that's going on here.
Did you actually is one of
my ex specially vocal fry?
Did you see what his um, his lower
third was where they call it the Kyron
and it says nasal alien.
Right, right. So Vinny,
no, that my friends have
my back through anything.
It's just always going to
have that friend reassurance.
And especially for me because I don't
talk to too many people outside of my car.
Do you order espresso? Of
course not. You know me at all.
We in him auto express, so I order, I uh,
I always give an extra stair to the
person that says, oh my God, me too.
I judged them so harsh. So we went
to the hotel and the lady was like,
this is your espresso machine. She checked
us in and I said, where's the machine?
An Espresso machine. I love when somebody
has poor grammar in front of one of us.
And then we ask them on to keep
saying it. You're going, yeah,
what can you make with this?
Just expresses,
um, but anyways, back to Vinny. Vinny,
he's doing some interesting things with
the look. The makeup is really intense.
It looks like maybe midway
through a performance of cats,
the musical, it's like
there's an a, there's a,
a costume change cause
there's very detailed and,
and very profound levels of black eye
makeup with it's not just black and like,
uh, um, it's,
it's kind of artistically applied so
that it looks like the eyes wrap further
back up along the temple. Well, I don't
know if you have another clip, but maybe,
oh, there's a, yeah,
there's a lot going on.
Me. I don't want to be that,
like that woman. I don't
want to be that muscular man.
I just want to be this alien. I want
to be able to like turn people's heads.
I want you to be terrified me.
But I also want you to think I'm beautiful
because that's what I'm attracted to.
When people
see this.
This is interesting
why? It seems pretty common to me.
Just your everyday kind of guy.
The Psych Guy Space
Alien, Babe. I'm sorry.
I forgot your Pronoun. Your
space. This is, yeah. Oh,
what's your pronouns? Yeah, well
there's, there's a lot going on.
I want to terrify people though.
It almost makes me feel like this
person wants attention, but I wouldn't
know. I wouldn't stoop so
low as to what are you doing?
Wait, are you saying that this person,
hold on, let me get this straight.
You're saying that this person isn't
right in the head and they just want
attention even if it's negative attention.
What's Your Pronoun? Wait is out.
Is that what you're implying?
That this isn't,
we shouldn't support this young
person and and becoming a nasal alien,
a nasal alien. How dare
you? You're anal, anal,
your alien phobic right now I know
and I should be open to alien.
You should be open to
everything in this era of dairy.
Tell me what the gender of
an alien person will be like.
A question from
Sam's friend has a point.
The reason why I call myself
alien is because alien is
never associated with sex.
It's like genderless. It's sex less. Yeah.
And that's why I started saying alien.
Yeah.
I like that. You do? Yeah.
I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know if you'd like where
you were about to hear next though.
Cause this next part,
it's not a lot to like
I went in also to see if actually
I can do some of everything. Uh,
yeah. That, that was the
first thing. Genderless.
Really just have like enough and just
not have any sex for the rest of my life.
Like you can't even get like, it's like,
it's like there's nothing there like
a mannequin.
Just be like, Hey, hi. How are you?
What's your name? What's Your Pronoun?
Hey, will you remove
everything and leave a nub?
Maybe.
Maybe just a mental health
counseling would help.
Well it sounds like someone's
got a problem with their
PP. Some something happen.
There's,
there's some,
something's wrong and someone needs
to see a shrink before he removes his
genuine.
Why wait till after.
I do hope they have to go through some
kind of counseling before you remove your
genitals, Dick and balls off. I want it.
I want my nub, I want to be a space alien.
So I, I, I want to terrify people
for them having to be like, wow,
that's pretty attractive too.
It's a very complicated one.
Most trained psychologist
and they'd be like,
we're going to keep you here overnight.
And you were to start
this again in the morning.
Yeah, it's a lot. Uh,
this niche right here is about
a change to a world. I know.
It means a lot coming from, you know,
my friends are these creatures that the,
I've handpicked and found in
different places in times in my life.
They're probably the realest people
I know out of everyone I met,
which speaks of volumes.
What show is this? Um, I'm not
sure. It's on e it's on e I.
F I think it's like botched
plastic surgery dudes. I know,
I know he was on that show. Sorry, I
dunno. Somehow I came down botched. Yeah,
it is what it is. Yeah. Yeah.
So I think this may have been on the your
mom's house face book group page where
this originated from.
And then I went down this rabbit hole
of this guy's videos and it turns out he
has been transitioning into
an alien since he was like 16.
Like he's,
he's always hated himself and the
way he looks and he really, really,
really wants to be, and he looks even
crazier now. Like that's narrative now.
He black, he blacks out his
eyes so that they're all black.
It's fucking terrifying dude.
You hear the similarities though,
between Zeeman,
Garth.
Yeah. I like that. I like that.
I like that.
I like that
pink haired Lady. It's funny. I like
that though. I really like that.
Uh,
so I've been following Garth on
Instagram and the g g sorry. Yeah.
And they've been teaching him,
he's been doing those, uh,
videos that are only up for like the day,
like those,
what do they call the snapchats?
Yeah, basically on Instagram.
And they taught you start.
Yeah.
And they've taught him
link in bio or swipe up.
So now he'll be like, um, um, first it's
the fake. Yeah. It's the fake smile.
Like, hi, I'm here right now.
I'm at south by southwest,
swap up, swap up. Like,
he's so bad at it. It's so great. I was
watching him today just like cringing.
He's so bad at it. Yeah. It's just
not as thing. You know, he, you know,
he's a successful singer. I get that
he entertains millions of people,
but the social media,
he needs like a coach.
He needs someone to help him be more
natural at that stuff. Yeah, he does.
Because it's all about authenticity
on that medium. You know, it's like,
um, also I wanted to point out that, uh,
every week now after we do the podcast,
if you go to our Facebook page,
it's facebook.com/your
mom's house podcast.
We were doing a live video,
a studio m at studio m and a we,
you know, we talked to you
guys, we answer questions, uh,
because it's all about you. You keep
talking. You, y'all did it. Y'All did.
Y'All day.
[inaudible] so many maps.
Oh, there you go. Even the dog says,
yeah, he hair. She goes, thank you.
That's all.
So, um, so they're teaching
him to be like a real
yeah, they're, they're doing a makeover,
I think of his social media. Yeah.
And the Instagram's
getting a little better.
Like he started to do more frequent
posts, but the snapchats, the,
your story parts, they're there. They
need work. Let's just put it that way.
Cause he, every time teaching the ultimate
Dad Boehner had seen there's nothing,
no better environment for a dad
boner. Then technology, you know,
they're all thumbs. They
don't so excitable. Yeah.
And the thing is too is like you can tell
somebody like, look at the guy. Oh God.
But you can tell someone's
like, okay, Garth and right.
Go cause then there's always a pause
before he starts his thing. Yeah.
I got real excited. He's
like, hey yeah, and waves.
Yeah. Hey guys. Oh, we're just
hanging out. Did he? Oh Gee.
I don't want to say what's up to
Bozeman, Montana. Yeah. Great time
going to blow your city. Excited about
that. Going to Shreveport, Louisiana.
Excited about that. You're like, you're
not excited about going to Sri port.
Shut out crap and energy when she has.
Okay,
dad.
Right.
We're at south by south.
I'm going to show you the one that's
made out of bamboo. Look at this night.
This has a really nice sound to,
this one is made by drying out the
bamboo poking holes through walls,
dividing sections that, oh
shit. Close that up yet.
Poking holes through all those kind
of putting the beans in. Got It.
And then the beans go from one
section to the next. No kidding.
Draping down and making it right.
Yeah.
That's the other thing I like about
this. It's boring, but he's also excited.
They gag Boehner. Slash. Board. Wow.
Right. You don't get that a lot crosses.
It crosses two worlds came together.
Borings
and dad like all on hold on your pants.
Are you going to come
and you're right. Oh Wow.
We hear it pretty nice. Huh?
Oh,
the other way.
Now he showed it to you like it was
two tits like you think of the east.
Yeah. It was super stoked about you.
She'll go in the next room with you.
Thank you sir. But that he has to explain
to me how the rain stick work. I mean,
look, if you've been in a mall since
1990 you fucking seen these. Yeah.
It'd be a real idiot nights to know
how the rain stick fucking works. Yeah,
it has.
Keep it going and definitely if you use
the turning motion and explained earlier
and levering back and forth,
no shit.
Okay. Now you can try it the
other way. Wait a minute.
You made a ton of those.
Well of the beans go down that way.
No Shit.
Yeah,
you gotta be kidding me. He's like, yeah,
you can just keep doing that for days
that it won't stop making that noise.
Dad's been smoking dope. I think so.
Yeah. He's high. He's a dope dad.
Definitely.
I get home.
We've got a few on for days like
that. Oh Wow. I don't have to worry.
You won't drive your neighbor's
crazy with this instrument.
Okay.
I find even an answer. Is it
really an instrument? I mean,
who plays the rain stick? I
fucking guy guidance. He'll be,
he plays that hacky sack lifestyle.
The fucking guy kiss up. Thinking about
that space. Alien can, I now are fine,
but I was so attracted.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. Should
complete, what'd you rather?
Yeah.
What'd you
take a cruise?
You're sharing a room
with the anal finger.
Stinky butt hole lady
or the space alien kid.
You're in a fucking cruise
ship room for a week.
Um, you got to have meals together.
You do your shuffle board.
You're being go activities together.
You guys are together.
You're a couple for a
week on a cruise ship.
I think space aliens probably easier
to hang out with. I don't think so.
I think he is a vortex of
emotional need. Yeah, that's true.
He's going to rail age.
She's nasty.
She's like living with a Frat Guy,
but the alien guy,
he's going to drain you emotionally.
She's like,
come over and just sit on your
fucking face. And he's like a,
an emo 13 year old girl.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
But I'm just thinking like what if the
whole time she's just like some of my
fingers smell it. Yeah.
But you've been to college.
Isn't that what that is when
dudes hanging out, I guess,
is that what you and your
slap Dick Friends did all
the time? Smelling fingers,
lighting farts, guys
do. I thought, I dunno.
I just feel like it's more pervasive
with her. I think it's going to be,
there is no joke in it.
She's like fucking smell like shit.
Yes Karen. It smells
like shit. So my panties,
something like fresh shit does.
You're saying that you think
she's relentless with it?
Like she can't go to
another topic and then,
and then as the week progressed
she's like stay for with no shower.
Nasty and you're like,
yeah,
and you guys are on a cruise ship
and it's like the Caribbean cruise,
so it's real sweaters and the
room's small. We got one of those.
We've got the inside room,
there's no balcony, no window.
Now the alien guy.
The problem is you're going to have to
walk around with him a lot and people are
going to be like,
what's up with those two?
And you're gonna have a lot of eyeballs
on you and he's going to make a big
spectacle of himself every time
he go eat somewhere. Oh My god,
why is everybody staring at me? And then
he's going to do that thing of like, God,
there's someone knowing God,
don't assume my pronoun.
He can get old person's death. Is that
a man or a woman? Let me, he'll be like,
I'm neither God is it so hard ass?
My Pronoun Bitch,
I'm a fucking nasal alien.
He's going to have a shirt made up
that says that the, of course bitch,
I'm a nasal alien and then he's going to,
it's going to be really embarrassing.
Whereas the asshole girl, she's not an
embarrassing on a public public. Yep.
She'll be, she'll be annoying in the
cabin but not in front of everybody else.
Yeah, we're in public. People will
walk by and go, oh, what does it smell?
Hassles stinks.
Horrible.
Oh I guess she would make me laugh more.
I think she would make me laugh cause he
kind of reminds you of your sister's on
ready. So it's like, so maybe
I would, but then again,
do I want to cruise with
my sisters for a week?
It'd be maybe,
can we make it a three day cruise?
Well, let's say if you had to
choose between two occupations,
one being you're the nasal alien and
you have to go through life trans
transitioning into an alien or your job
is to not shower and do those asshole
committee pretty good. You're
all, this is your skill,
thank you and Milo skill and my other,
would you rather champ
would you say thank you.
It's your job and you
can still do comedy but
these jobs might,
I would definitely do asshole videos,
finger my asshole videos and them
over over becoming a nasal alien.
Of course. Well I feel like
the nasal alien, you just
have to wipe the makeup off.
No,
I'm saying I'm transitioning to be a
nasal alien that's going to occupy more of
my time than you think.
That is such a full time Gig.
Of course transitioning and he was like,
we have to give this guy a fucking show.
They really should actually, I'd watch
that Guy Shell. It exists obviously.
Just on, I thought that was
an episode about, Oh, I think
you're right. Okay. Yeah,
no, this was a segment
to a, a different show.
But that kid needs his own reality show.
I'd love to watch what's
going on mentally there.
Doctor drew needs to intervene.
This flickering light.
Unreal. Ah, ah, ah.
Wait a minute. So wait, what did
you, you decided on being the ass.
Wait,
aren't you
ruined my life,
but both will ruin your life.
I'm trying to do a dental update and I
totally realize that you didn't explain.
What do you mean it's going
to ruin your life? Both. Well,
why would your asshole vids row in
your life? You know what's another one?
Both where people say like idea.
Both idea. We'll say idea. God,
that's fucking terrible. Okay. Um, I,
it'll ruin your life to do these assholes.
That's why. Well, because I heard an
interview with Tara Patch or I can,
she made a great point. She's
like, if you want to do porn,
be prepared for everybody in
your life to know your pastor,
your Stepdad, your kids. You went to first
grade with everyone's gonna find out.
So as a ruin your life though,
that wouldn't ruin your life.
Your mother knowing that
she'd be like,
you've always been nasty.
What's the big deal?
You don't think your,
you think your son wants to know
that his dad does asshole smelling
videos. I think it's fine.
I think it's not a big deal.
You don't think that's going
to mess up his school life and,
and I mean I look the alien thing
is way worse or until you know,
I think it's fine.
It's just an asshole. You're
just, you're just being nasty.
I wouldn't say it's quite like porn.
I mean it is.
There was the one blurt out video where
she's clearly fingering her asshole.
Yeah. So putting that out there
would be a little uncomfortable.
Wait a minute.
But what about our marriage?
Like I'm going to have to smell
your asshole. Why does it smell it?
Cause I live with you. I sleep next to
you. Shine for days and days. Oh yeah.
You'll get used to it though.
I don't want to get used to it.
I know it's not desirable, but we signed
up for this. This is our life now.
This is what we're doing. I guess it's
still better than being an alien. I, yeah,
I take the asshole stuff over alien too.
It's not that weird.
It's just like the gate.
It's just like the gays.
The gays do the same thing,
you know? God Damn Dude.
Um,
all right,
so I was trying to read these
dental updates we got. Oh,
I have one too. You do? Yeah,
of course. All right here
can be back in the mood.
All right.
Just wanted to give you a dental update.
I recently went to the dentist after
not seeing one in almost 15 years.
Holy Fuck. Last time I went
was when I was 12 oh my God.
I had to get a baby tooth bold.
The dentist forgot to give me Nova
came before we started pulling.
Woo.
Told me to stop whining when I told him
how bad it hurts. Oh my God. Since then,
I've been terrified of the dentist.
After listening to your
show for several years,
I finally told my jeans up,
got my life and went to a dentist.
Besides my teeth being all buttery
and needing a thorough cleaning,
I had no cavities.
Alright.
Thank you for your
constant dental shaming.
It's just as a fact of
effective as fat shaming.
Just like the gays Matt. Wonderful
Map. Yeah. Um, we have another one,
but go ahead.
Go ahead.
Big Update for me.
I'm getting my new crown this Thursday.
Today's Tuesday.
And it's been misery for the last two
weeks because I've had to chew on the left
side of my mouth, which is when
they fucking tell you to do right.
And now what happened was I got a piece
of meat stuck behind the temp crown.
Oh God. And they tell you not to floss.
What do you do? But it was hurting.
It was really hurting. And so, you know
what I said, fuck it. And I fought,
I flossed and one was,
it sucked.
It didn't pop up just a hour or two.
I was like trying to get it out with my
fingers and then I just lost in it and
it didn't pop off.
So I've been flossing.
I have an idea. Yeah, go ahead.
What about doing a video like the asshole
video lady about your teeth and how
you don't and
you make a video like that. You
go like, Oh, I'm not going to fly.
I haven't flossed in days.
I bet it smells real bad.
You run your teeth, your finger
around your teeth. Got It. Thank you.
Thank you. Why don't you like don't
want to do that? It's disgusting.
I first of all, I can't go a day without
flossing. I think that's revolting.
I don't want to do that. Yeah.
Okay. What would you rather do?
The flossing video or the dirty
ass whole video. Of course,
the flossing video.
Seriously,
you would rather do the asshole video
because I would rather have a dirty ass
hold on a dirty mouth. I get a finger it
and smell it. My ass was pretty clean.
Dude. Are you hearing the nonsense
that you're spewing right now?
My butthole because it's hairless. I,
because I bid day wash it every day.
It's fine, dude. Like I could skip three
shower days because I have a day so much.
Damn,
I didn't realize you're fucking out of
your God damn fine and my bowel movements
are pretty clean. They pinch right off.
There's not a lot of remnants right now.
Just some air that comes out of
there and it's not real sweet.
Like she was saying,
it's really,
really bad and I think the idea that
you're trying to sell that you would do
that over a dental video is crazy.
You can taste all the time and when
I have a floss, I just feel dirty.
I don't think that you would finger your
asshole and then and then smell it for
a while on video. Yes. No, you wouldn't
then do the flossing. You're lying.
Why would I lie? The philosophy was so
disgusting. A minute, wait a minute.
Didn't we just say that you shouldn't
shut on people for their preferences.
I don't like to go camping.
This is the same thing trying
to convince this one's dumb,
Tommy being hurtful. Now
I think you should not be
hurtful smelling dirty floor.
I'm like, God, you guys are so
disgusting grosser than smelling a shit.
No one believes that.
What's not to believe in my mind.
Fingering your ass home dirty food
over dirty plaque in your mouth.
I'm just going to jump over to
the next one because this is so,
but I'm not even done
with my dental updates.
So I'm going to get a new
crown and then as a treat,
I've decided to have my teeth whitened
at the dentist's office after my crowd.
So when I come home next, oh no,
sorry. Thursday I'm at brand new crown.
A zoomed out there because I realized
the one flaw and the Gel whitening when
you do it yourself is that you can't
gauge how wide it's going to be like it
sucks. It takes too long. Just fucking try
it this way and see if I like it. Good.
Are you doing it the same when we went to
the same dentist? I like that guy. Yeah,
I like him too. We'll see Dr
Farts. He's good. It's not a,
here's another email. What's up? Mommies?
I had to send a dental update after mommy.
Tina talked about replacing her
badly fit crown. It's the worst time,
eight twice a week.
Flosser thanks to the show twice a week,
pump it up to once a day and then
we'll talk. I put off getting a crown
over a root canal for over six years.
Every cleaning my dentist would ask if
I wanted to spend 1500 on a crown and I
would ask if it was necessary.
The answer was always, you know,
of course whenever you have the money.
I never knew this was code
for fucking immediately.
I recently went to a new dentist chain
called modern dentistry and it was the
shit I tried to put off the crown again
and they said the tooth was developing
micro fractures.
Ooh,
I said it was in a hurry and they
convinced me to stay with 20% off. Great.
Promised a two hour crown. Oh,
oh it sounds. He numbed me up,
ground the tooth down and scan the shape
with a three d scanner or the size of a
toothbrush, the design, the crown,
the crown in the computer and Oh,
they designed the,
the crown and the computer and they uh,
they machine it in under 30 minutes.
I don't know what that means.
They even did the general cleaning
while I waited on the crown. Oh my God.
After installing it, they uh, they
show you an x ray of how well it went.
I'm telling you this
shit is big time jeans.
[inaudible] I know you probably trust
Steve Harvey's Dennis to keep your shit on
fleek when you're squishing nasty molding
goo into your choppers and waiting two
weeks for a phone.
Remember that you can get
your life to not sure when,
but you call that a listener for standing
up while wiping like a four year old
man and I stand with them. Many parents
give up on teaching technique at four.
We are so lucky to have you and
top dog to give higher titer,
wiping education to those less fortunate,
keeping it in greasy and mom
[inaudible] thanks for that Steve Bro.
Cheers Kyle.
[inaudible]
well, Kyle, I wasn't even aware that
they could do a crown instantly.
Modern dentistry. I know. I thought we
were going to somebody modern and I'm,
I'm upset now that there was such
a thing that I could've done.
I would've gladly, I hate waiting two
weeks to the temp. It's misery. Terrible.
It's misery. Absolutely
terrible. But then again,
my veneers that I had done really, really
nice, took about two weeks as well.
And it was, it was well worth it because
the guy like hand crafted my teeth.
You know what I mean? Yeah. I
don't know. I don't fucking know.
I don't fucking know.
Um, it's been a minute. So what
do you say we revisit some, uh,
new submissions of hi mommy thing. Oh,
I'm so excited. These are my favorites.
There are a lot of fun.
Here we go
for you today. Hey, how are
you doing? I'm just blasting.
Thank [inaudible] guys,
how are you? I'm sorry,
I'm just glass and thanks for asking.
You're welcome. What can I say? Ah,
I think I'm going to go double
pipe classic and get a media Mocha.
Yeah.
You know my teeth or an a plus like toms,
but I can do that.
[inaudible] I was a blessed. Yeah,
I could do that. Yes, please.
Can I get do anything? Do
you want anything? You can
get me a small friends. Ah,
yeah. I got a thing later with a
bunch of guys just hanging out.
Totally nonsexual.
Um,
could I get a small French Vanilla,
Vanilla. That's it. For six days we
were milking. Thank you. Thank you.
Wow. Really? Really.
You know what I really liked about this
one is his calm demeanor key to it.
I think he really was really ups the
value. Yeah. Stay calm. He was like,
Hey Hitler. And she was like,
hi, how's it going? Like,
yeah, really good, calm, calm.
The stop that one.
And that makes it sound like it's normal.
And that's just natural conversation.
Yeah.
I think this whole experiment really
has taught us how little other people
listen. He was really, he goes very
rarely do you get like, yeah, I'm sorry,
what was that? A lot of times
just like response automated.
That's Ian. Thanks Ian. Yeah,
the one time we got pushed back is when
that girl went straight to the window
and was like, Hey, I'm just wondering,
would you ever date your mom? He was like,
excuse me. He leaned out of the window.
He was like, what are you saying to me?
Yeah.
Sub Kane.
How are you doing tonight?
Are you honestly a little
bit of a dog Dick afternoon,
if you know what I'm saying.
But that's a whole of being.
So I'm ready for you to give me the
grease here. Slashing the menu real quick.
Sorry.
Take your time.
You guys have so many options here.
It's like multiple choice.
Wow. Wow. Oh God. Wow. Han Jokes. Okay.
I'm going to start with a uh, nick
double pipe classic. You can I get that?
Gum and mustard.
Oh my God.
He said only muster a yes.
I'm not sure. Anything else?
And then I'm not seeing
it on the menu here.
Do you guys still make the fuck
my stoma? Wow. I'm sorry. The mic.
Chicken deluxe. I loved
the misdirect. Okay.
Can I get one of those and then, uh, can
I get that with a site? A thousand ranch?
Yes. Alright. And then, let's see.
I don't know why I'm having so
much trouble with the menu. Uh,
where are the dudes at? Oh,
I'm sorry. What was that?
Where the dudes at like coke. Pepsi. Oh,
okay. Uh, you have root beer, right?
Is it bikes, root beer or
what kind? Jesus. Yeah.
Okay. Um, you know what, I actually
have a long road trip head,
so I need something with gimme
a little stand them mine.
I'm going to do a large diet coke. Jesus.
This guy's just, he's got all of them.
I mean, yeah, I need the large diet.
I need something that's going to
help me keep my, uh, I, uh, I,
I on the road, um, no,
I think I'm all finished and I'm all done.
Yeah.
Can you go ahead and give me my reward?
The scenes all kind of dirty
and disgusting. I can't
really read it. Unreal.
Oh my God. Give me the total. Oh, amazing.
Thanks Gina.
God, this was a, Oh my
God. Masterclass. Yeah.
You know how to do this.
I cannot believe what I just
witnessed that was varsity level.
I mean there's people listening to you
now that must have missed some of these
references because yeah, he did so
many. And he went deep in the vault,
were talking, I wrote some of
them down just to reference them.
His name is Landon. Thank
you. [inaudible] on the road.
It's in the first class.
41st 40. That's um,
uh, not, not autistic. What are
they correct. Tourettes camp. Yeah.
So that guy had terrains. Johnny Davidson.
Yeah, that's right. Johnny Davidson. Well,
stamina. Stand them up.
Stand them. We know that one.
Where the dudes at that is God old.
That is really,
really, really old man. So where are
the dudes? That was one of your bed.
That's it. That was our very first
call from monkey. Todd. Yeah.
Yeah.
And he called into TMZ. Yeah, I spoke
to, what's his name? Harvey. Yeah.
Harvey Keitel and Harvey Harvey 11.
I don't know what the
fuck that guy's name.
Yeah.
Tansy and him where the dude's
yet and where are there?
Where the dudes at is from a story from
your, when your college friends at a bar.
Some guy came up to him, he was like,
hey man, we're the dudes at that's right.
And he got Super Mad. So that's that
story. Dog Dick Afternoon. I mean
that was a pitch I had for a
show that never got picked up.
Really? Where uh, you masturbate
different dogs. Right.
And just to see how they come in different
[inaudible] what happened to that
pitch? Got Shut down. I
don't know what happened,
but you know what fuck vice
was gonna make it for a second.
Well, you know what? Now that
you've gotten more well known,
you're very famous comedian. Bring it
back, page it to Netflix. Like, well yeah,
maybe. I mean it might be
more of a HBO property, right?
They think they really go outside the box.
They're like really original stuff.
So God, Shit. Yeah. Fuck my stoma is, oh,
old school reference. Yeah. I
don't even know. I know of that.
I think that was someone that was having
sex with somebody that had a stoma.
I think you were talking about
if I want to, I want to remember,
I'm not entirely sure,
but I want to say we were talking about
what happens with people with those,
um, and that you said, you
know, fuck my whatever.
Fuck my stoma and then
that became a a drop. Yup.
It's always nice. Yeah. People
catch you saying dumb shit. Yeah.
It becomes a nice little sound, rob.
Yeah. I mean, here's a, of course,
and that's fucked up. How I say that word
forever now Stan. Emma, I can't stop.
I don't say it right. I have to uncross
the letters. Stand them up. Stand them up.
Stand them off. I mean that, this,
we may be one of the all time,
most well crafted. Yeah. Hey Man. Fuck
my stoma. There it is. It's old school.
You can even hear the audio different.
Yeah. I mean he Mike's first mix.
Fuck my stoma. You hear that? Yeah. The
differences, but at least I can hear him.
He just started a dynamic
microphone. The Evie, my guy, the Ebi
did cardioid dynamic range.
Oh my God,
that was the first boring video. Yeah.
You know, we should do like, I killed it,
but we should do as, um, cause
we're almost here. But uh,
we should do an episode where we just
go through the early soundboards and
explain maybe some of the drops.
Yeah, sure. From the early years.
I see people asking you about
references sometimes. Yeah. Uh,
or just maybe take a little bit.
Yeah.
Wow. What a talent. Thank
you. What a talent. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. There's one more
here. You want to impress this one? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Awesome fee.
Many of those, let's say
his head whipped around,
he was like,
oh hi mommy. In a second. I'm just
glass on the menu here. You know,
I can only see what's his high
end type on the corner there. No.
F A r t am I knew I got a
coupon here for a double,
like classic. Could you repeat
that? I got a coupon for the,
the two quarter pounder meal.
Okay,
I'll get that please. I know. Um,
I don't want to be fat like burnt, so, you
know, I'll get a, uh, just a diet coke.
No, you know, and that's
for the first one. Um,
hang on. Where do you want my super
bowl please? Yes, it is. Yeah.
And for the second, the second training,
uh, you know, we were just down in Boston,
see a Dj, dad mouth, you know, and
they had a monkey purples down there.
Do you guys have that to drink?
No. No. Let me know. Okay.
They must sound like a nonbinary menu, you
know? Uh, so for the other one, you know,
all those have probably a root
beer to drink, please. No. Okay.
Second Window.
I think jeans.
Wow. I love the Kayla and Michael. Great
job. I love the incorporation of a,
your act in the very beginning. And
then B, I like the, you know, I mean,
we haven't had somebody put in a, you know
what I mean? You know what I mean? Like,
yeah. You know, I also, like he said,
I don't want to be fat like burnt bird.
He didn't say like Bert. Right.
Subtle distinction. And I like that.
Really good work. I liked the use of the
coupon. Yeah, very earnest and very, uh,
good. Uh, a r t a very vulnerable
to incorporate the use of a coupon.
Very sweet touch. Sure. Super impressed.
Yeah. Good stuff. As always guys.
He's just killing it with these blocks.
A R as a reminder that
the super soft Hoodie,
Jean j e n a dream
Ron Astro hoodies for a long time.
So it's a sale. Please go to my site,
Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com. Click on
the store and you can just see the,
the uh,
the new Hoodie,
the gene hoodie in addition to
the other shirts that we have.
Thank you for your support
on that. And um, jeans,
congratulation again. Uh,
you have a special coming in.
More details will be announced for that.
Uh,
it's going to be coming up pretty soon,
so fucking weight.
You can see her on the road getting ready
for it. Yeah. Thanks Jean. And yeah,
that'd be great.
By the way,
W can we mention that on this episode?
Tom and I got dressed today without
seeing each other prior. Yeah,
I came home after you so I didn't
even know what you're wearing.
And we both ended up wearing
identical outfits today.
Black hooded sweatshirt.
You were in that a Chola la one.
Yeah,
I'm wearing the Jamie Young Jamie.
Yeah.
Powerful, powerful,
powerful sweatshirt. Um,
which I bought by the way. Nice
support. Yeah. To support. Um,
yeah. And we're wearing jeans.
You're wearing dad colored Jean.
Let me justify these genes.
They need a little bit of justification.
I don't, I normally don't
do light denim. Yeah.
But these are specific nineties cuts.
But I buy from the lucky brand online.
They don't sell them in the stores.
They're called the little Maggie's honor.
I think that these chains speak
for themselves and this, uh,
attempt to make them seem
like they're acceptable.
It should be dismissed. I let you
decide. You know what? I'm not,
dudes can't wear a light denim.
I think girls can rock light denim boys.
It's not even cute. It's not even
cute, bro. The state rests, your honor.
We believe that the evidence show,
let the record show,
that's brown lock.
We used to do brown lock where we
would uncover mysteries behind these
mysteries. Can we talk
about, first of all,
I'm surprised we didn't even get
there today. You took two shits today.
Let's go through them. Um,
yeah. Well wait a minute.
How do you know about too?
Because this morning we were like,
are you sure about that? Yeah, I did.
I did. I did, but it was, it was,
it was on the way. Sorry. Cause
it was right before the shower.
I got dressed and everything.
Yeah, we were talking,
we were in the middle of a discussion.
Yeah. Like a business discussion. Yeah.
And I love this.
My favorite thing that you do,
like it's a pretty serious discussion and
then you just turn around and you walk
away and you walk out. And I was like,
oh, hello. Yeah, we're not discussing.
You're like,
I got to shit.
Can you tell me you have to ship before
you turn her around and walk away.
Okay. Um, and then we were eating
lunch. Yeah. And I'm still eating.
And you're like, I got a shit.
Oh, I really got to shit.
It was like a little bit like,
ah, the second one, by the way,
to say I gotta eat alone.
You had finished everything on the plane.
Yes you did.
I was getting a second round of food
you saw in the second round snack.
Yeah, but it was just, I mean, come on.
It was a follow up like a little treat.
It wasn't, this is what I'm
eating right now. Anyway.
I will always want to make the point.
The second one was a lot sloppier
and messier. Let's talk about it.
I'm trying to travel.
I made fitness.
It was clean food. You know,
it was healthy food. There
was Kale, there was chicken.
Yeah. Felt the far it's
coming. It's my new favorite,
eh?
Eh,
I like how she says that I was for,
it might be the best one of those.
That's a real drawn out. When I like it.
He know who I keep thinking about.
There's the come lady.
I can't get her out of my mother
for some reason.
She's been stuck in my mind.
Yeah. I've come all over my face.
I think that her issue with men not
wanting to touch their comment and
that is not an issue, is that you're
trying to say no, it was like when she,
when I thought she was just like a,
an a lay person and then I find out she's
a professional sex worker. It's like,
well yeah guys,
you know are going to be weird to you that
they're calm and everything like this.
Not a big deal. Right. What,
what's not the big deal guys don't really
want to be that close to it. I don't,
but then,
but the problem is they expect her to
be into the com I think is her gripe.
But then we'll never even
touch his own commerce
so many times. She also, did you
hear her part of that where she said,
or even taste his own,
but like even when do you meet?
When did any sensible reasonable guy
be like, I mean, yeah, I'll taste it.
No one does that. No. But it also, and
here's my thing with it, it's like, well,
if you're a sex worker, it's part
of the Gig that someone asks you,
hey, will you swallow? I'm assuming
you negotiate ahead of a time,
I guess what the sex, we're like, hey,
will you swallow my come? Yeah, sure.
So you can't really complain
about it. Yeah. You shouldn't be.
You know what I'm saying? Like,
it's a business transaction.
If it doesn't have to just
come, you know, go on strike.
I think we should go on strike
against, come, uh, come strike
bold stance. But you know what I
mean? Like you can't, you can't, uh,
fault the guy for not wanting to taste
his don't come if he's paying for your
services.
You know what I mean?
Like that's his right to not want to eat
the calm because he's paying for you to
do whatever.
It's like,
now we're kind of making a leap on that
because I did see something that said
escort for her. I don't want
a hundred percent. So let's
say, let's assume she is,
let's just put that, we're making the
assumption that discussion. Yeah, I don't,
you know who knows what the real story
is, but if she is, it's like, okay,
well it's not your place to judge.
The guys who don't want to eat their come.
Most guys don't want to eat their
own comp. Most guys don't write.
I've never known a guy who's been
like, I love it. I love the taste.
Have you known anybody that
was like, I love? Not Openly.
I mean, I'm sure we know.
We know somebody is eating their
come right now. As they're listening,
they're like, I'm going to
write an email and let's just,
right. Yeah. I don't know a lot of,
I mean obviously I'm sure there's a lot
of people that are, I'm sure into it,
but into their own come,
it's probably a smaller percentage
into your own Tj's interesting.
You think that that's lesser than the
guy that's into other guys? Of course.
Because that,
because that's not that.
I mean there's definitely guys
and girls that are into com.
Yeah. Tasting it, swallowing it.
Either there's thoughts
out that's not that crazy.
To be into your own I think is
a bit more of a stretch. Yeah.
Cause your own fluid in usually the,
the thrill would be that it's
a belonging to a second party,
nonsexual person.
And I'm into things like pup play and
that's where we're supposed to get
familiar with your own things. Yeah.
And it's not sexual, it's not sexual.
It's good. Good point. It's just
science could always just do,
I'm fucking come run,
come on.
It never seems to get any less humiliated.
Come run. In other words,
one big fucking Bull Lake.
Of course though.
And I also know you're deep.
Your fucking Dick back inside me where
I've still got reminds if your calm and
then expect me to fucking suck off
my mind so I'll just finish up.
Let me do the camera. Let me have
a shower. You jumped in the shower.
Fuck me in the shower.
Clean each other in the shower.
Electrical.
I love her.
You know what I do love these
are lower class English girls,
dare you. You know what I mean?
Like no, I don't know what you mean.
Really dark are white trash is
far less charming. You know,
our white trash girls are just not
as as charming as the English accent.
Maybe it's the accent.
I mean,
I am assuming she's a bit trashy and
I'm assuming a class distinction here,
but I do love these chaps or
whatever it is. A film in Oxford.
She's a Cambridge,
the fellow in the shower.
Yeah, she's talking about
her tutorials. All right.
We've got to run as always.
Thank you guys for listening to our show.
A lot of heavy hitting topics today,
but it was huge farts and
burps and bowel movements,
knowing your fingers.
We're lucky in that.
A super mature
DJ boy butter. Oh, okay. One of my
favorites doing songs right now.
I mean, he is killing it. He got us
the hottest guy in the game. Well he,
he's the one that did the just like the
gay song, then I can't stop playing.
I mean, I play it on my phone
all the time. It's so good.
You know that song, right?
How does it go? Um, I think here at I,
I'm so into that song that I have it.
He are memorizing the episode was in,
this is his,
yeah. This is amazing. Mom. You're my son.
I'm your mom. Your mom. I
asked him when you did your mom
sounds really good.
I would hear my son.
I'm your mom.
It's just like the gate.
So that's his really good. He
submitted another song. Okay.
Featuring this as DJ boy
butter featuring Mack SF.
What? Now? That's a vaults kind
of guy. That's what real falls.
Um, here's a guys. Google Mac. Sf m. A,
c. K. S. F. Yeah. Before pot.
Pause the show now as Google that
before you listened to this song,
here's a little taste.
If you don't have time to Google
anyways,
that was wrong is what's your
Pronoun Featuring Mac SF.
My Dj boy butter. Wow.
I can't wait to hear it.
And then we are going to go Facebook
live right now. Quick debate.
That sound drop.
Oh,
is that pleasure or pain that
somebody in the midst of both? Yeah.
Both. Yeah. Both. Hmm.
All right, let's go live on this
bitch. I'm pulling it up, right? Yeah,
my apple treats. Okay. It's
just like the gays. All right.
It's just like the gays.
Thanks again for listening
and here is that song.
We'll see you next week.
Bye Jean.
Yeah. What's this? I heard you talking
shit about me at the bar last night.
Z.
There's so many options.
Well,
throw them in the dungeon and there
was a wet butt being and you're like,
hey, how are you? What's your
name? What's Your Pronoun?
They just wanted to confirm.
What's Your Pronoun? What's,
what's your Pronoun Ze Zer?
What's Your Pronoun?
Oh Wow, man.
I'm getting fucked in the ass by another
fuck right now.
Oh,
oh.
Oh.
Oh,
David.